a friend is lost on a parallel or then
we're gonna get him back the parallel
streets - / / Mobilicity - episode event
begins Tuesday February 21st on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie gorilla city we
got to break this out it's gonna be so
awesome the flash a team is going to
earth to to fight gorilla City the B
team is going to be left on earth 1 to
take care of another metahuman that's
kind of what they did last year so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway or you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video and I have a couple updates about
the video schedule for the next couple
of videos at the end of this oh my god
this is gonna be so amazing so they're
teasing flash versus Korat so part of
team flash goes to earth - the reason
for this like the reason they take the
people they do is because tom felton is
like the new special guest star of the
season of course you're gonna take him
Caitlin has a special connection to
Grodd she's the one that he really likes
obviously you're gonna take the flash
and Cisco is the next new super-powered
person who's a little bit better with
his abilities then say Wally who's
actually needed back in Central City so
Jesse quick Wally West team-up it'll be
fun to see what she's learned in the
time that we haven't seen her maybe she
can show Wally a couple new tricks so a
lot of you been commenting about why
they've been paying so much attention to
Wally's character like you think they're
gonna kill off Barry and it'll be
Wally's show no they just want to have
like really cool episodes where Wally
can be the flash of earth 1 while the
main flash is off doing things like this
in gorilla city for two hours so the
whole pitch just turns your head upside
down when you read the synopsis for the
episode because in the comics Gorilla
Grodd is one of Flash's biggest enemies
but what the TV show has done is sort of
aligned him with team flash for now that
might change in the future but here I'll
read the synopsis attack on gorilla city
Barry and team travel took a real a city
on earth to in face Grodd when Jesse
quick informs the team that her father
has been abducted Barry Caitlin Cisco
and Julianne voyage to earth to on a
rescue mission to save Harry from
gorilla City as they trek through the
forest Barry and the team are
immediately captured and brought to
Grodd Grodd tells them he needs their
help to stop so levar the leader of
gorilla City as so levar wants to invade
earth 1 meanwhile back on earth 1 Jesse
and Kid Flash
tima hit the streets to stop a metahuman
that can control gravity with HR and Joe
guiding them from STAR Labs so the big
thing about this is that we're gonna
meet so levar obviously guerilla city is
huge it's a two-part episode and it
doesn't start for two weeks so it's on
break next week I'll be doing bonus
videos but after that there'll be a run
of episodes I don't know if there'll be
another break before the end of the
season but this will get you guys really
pumped up if you're a big Rick & Morty
fan Keith David who's done a bunch of
voices on that show he's done a lot of
stuff he's a very identifiable voice is
going to be doing the voice for so levar
is anyone here even real am I the only
real person on earth maybe or maybe just
maybe we're all real you know me I'm
reversed Arab I have a short neck and
legs I went to college with hammer on
hey I saved ghost in the jars life in
Vietnam and Beth how many times have I
been a shoulder for you to cry off okay
so maybe we're just all fake so this is
a whole lot of stuff that I just dropped
in that synopsis let's pick through it
one is the fact that so levar is
actually the bad gorilla in this
equation normally gorilla grodd is evil
so levar is the good ape that's the way
it started out in the comics but what
they might be doing is if this is
straight up and they're not misleading
us there's not some big twist with Grodd
who's trying to mislead them then
they're just aligning Grodd with team
flash and he won't be their enemy or the
second option is is that they're trying
to be a little misleading in what Grodd
is doing is he is just misleading team
flash to trick them into helping him
take over a gorilla city so that he will
be the leader of their society because
the footage doesn't tell you a whole lot
here
but when you read soul of art's
backstory it sounds like there's gonna
be some big twist in this episode for
many years so levar is the leader of
gorilla city a hidden city of
hyper-intelligent gorillas renowned for
his wisdom and psychic powers he is
virtually unchallenged except by the
villainous Gorilla Grodd the rivalry is
so great that after so levar is captured
by humans garage follows him to Central
City to learn the secrets of so lavars
mind-control powers he succeeds in this
but the flash captures
him after solovar escapes and tells the
flash of Grod
so just assuming that there is no twist
and this synopsis is correct this is the
other way around so levar is the evil
one and Grodd is the good one
which just blew my mind when I read it I
actually thought that it was wrong like
somebody wrote this synopsis wrong
gorilla grodd's supposed to be the evil
ape
so borrowing from Cisco's Donkey Kong
joke flash versus super intelligent
gorilla best worst video game ever Grodd
gets sucked through the warp pipe into
gorilla City and they already have an
established culture of hyper-intelligent
apes that so levar is leading and he's
sort of the odd man out so if you
haven't seen that episode in a little
while or you don't remember grodd's
relationship with team flash Caitlin
always tried to help him but the way
they left it was kind of ambiguous like
Grodd should be pissed that they sent
him to gorilla City but the way Harrison
Wells talked about it it's a good place
so they'll probably have some fun when
the flash meets Grodd again for the
first time like oh yeah remember the
last time we saw each other you tricked
me and punch me through that Super Mario
warp pipe to earth to
[Music]
so we'll just see how they play it when
the episode drops but remember one of
the things on the future board that
they're trying to change is a giant
gorilla attack on earth one the news
headlines said cities still recovering
from gorilla attack so there was a
terrible gorilla attack destroyed most
of the city so if they don't change
things in so Lavar gets his way or it's
secretly Grodd is trying to control them
gorilla City leads an assault on central
city and just destroys almost everything
so I'm so excited about this maybe I'll
do a Gorilla Grodd bonus video next week
because he has really cool history on
the show it's a little bit different
from the comics but because of that
break leave all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments below there's so
many things that are going on right now
I'm so excited this is gonna be a lot of
fun in what's gonna happen with the
video schedule today is because they
dropped a new Iron Fist trailer I'm
gonna do my legends of tomorrow video
nicks then I'll do iron fist instead of
doing arrow in because the Legion is
starting tonight what's gonna happen on
Thursday is I'll do my Legion video
first then I'll do my arrow video so
after that I'll figure the video
schedule out but for the next couple of
videos it's gonna be legends of tomorrow
then more iron fist footage then Legion
then arrow so there's a whole bunch of
stuff coming I'll try to get through it
as fast as possible but if there any
video requests that you guys have just
leave them in the comments below
congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner Josh Oh Pete please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll remind
everyone when I post legends of tomorrow
in a couple hours while you wait for
that you can click here for the flash
episode and you can click here to
rewatch that iron fist trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video